well guys we're doing the mission taking
point outpost is ammonia okay let your
boy it's a boy psychobabble within the
main man oh [ __ ] get all this stuff out
for this main man Donald chump okay I
got a guy and stronger here so let's
stay let's do this no where's my gun God
get gun got quick sake I get good data
okay [ __ ] is that oh [ __ ] i love when
they put it like so far away i can't
even like think tumblr i liked our God
God God kept the more effective the
lockbox yes yes yes yes okay so I'm
gonna go topless I'm well [ __ ] it up
mmm-hmm going round and round and round
in the shares are set no [ __ ] you Sam a
railroad agent this cannot be good they
same innocent but are they look Don
knows are sure so many senses we gotta
keep to [ __ ] is that have a hunter like
what am I gonna say yeah now what
happened oh good they're all after him
that I'm sorry
okay okay okay shave this uh uh that it
sets a [ __ ] what okay chef worry
other guys go Oh is he the head fall off
I like that okay where's that that was
very nasty what I just did don't ever do
that to anyone you know I'm a
professional where's boomer there is
alright
ok ok ok open this gay play oh yeah oh
yeah
and I where's the radio I can't so much
[ __ ] here okay let's get good
okay let me see how much luxury this guy
has right now bayside person say this
guy it's the radio beacon bana now
really knows how good it is
and a radio beacon pile on larchmont
pylon I'll on a que and sorry
to build a [ __ ] radio beacon it looks
like that's one though
shuts what [ __ ] no I nice cap so there
we go
mmm
being like resources right crafting now
resources
fast travel time I get siren ring braman
scavenger station miscellaneous oh ok do
we not have one cuz we didn't [ __ ]
have fun ok
okay guy could get talked to Preston
Garvin yeah this guy he loves talking
he's just a chatter he's just a job as
simple as that oh good he's like nowhere
near me that's good o Jays Jays anyways
I don't play book one girl you know my
pie me on there right fine man that [ __ ]
where is he where the [ __ ] did he gone
out okay he's nowhere near make I've got
cut no one really knows where he is
think he's going back the sanctuary he
just looked traveler